heads up guys my name is China welcome
back to another code review of the
series in which you guys send me your
code and I take a look at it now this
time we're doing something we've never
done before we're actually going to be
looking at the same code we looked at
last time why because it was so good
that I just couldn't get enough of it
the reason being that we only really
took a look at half the code because I
got too distracted talking about memory
don't you hate it when that happens
talking with your friends and then
suddenly just start talking about memory
and just can't stop so yeah we're back
at it again with this physics engine the
previous video I will have linked up
there definitely take a look at it first
especially if you're interested in
memory and performance and that kind of
stuff in fact one of the reasons why I
really like this project is because it
actually gives us a few actionable items
to maybe fix and improve and optimize
and me as a boss manager I like
actionable items now I guess so what I
want to try and do here today is take a
look at the code that we haven't taken a
look at yet and I'm going to abstain
from talking about memory I guess but in
the future we might revisit this code
and Implement some of those
optimizations that I've talked about so
we'll get back into it maybe someday so
don't be too upset they're there okay so
taking a look at the solution Explorer
once again we can see that the project
is divided into a demo and also this
stoe physics engine module over here
which compiles into a static Library
this is the actual physics engine itself
it looks like and these are just things
that are used for this demo so this is
what we're going to focus on we're going
to see how this comes together now when
you're looking through code that isn't
your own it can be a little bit diff
difficult to piece it together in your
mind especially if you're a beginner and
you just don't have much experience what
I'm going to do is I'm going to show you
how I approach something like this even
though this is a relatively small code
base and it probably wouldn't take you
too long to just like read each file and
learn about how they work I mean this
isn't including the header files why
isn't it including the header files like
again this is some CMA configuration but
each one of these if I just hit alt o
using visual assist or control KO using
uh just visual Studios commands you can
see there is an HPP file however that's
like coming in as like an external item
see this is I don't know the project
structure is a bit weird I don't know
like exactly the CMA configuration
you've used here I don't really care to
be honest but yeah usually like it would
be good to see the header files here
especially because header files don't
necessarily have to have a CPP file
along with them right they could just be
a header file in which case I might be
missing entire files from here like you
can't assume that if you have a CPP file
you can just switch to the header file
and you'll see it and you therefore you
don't need to display them like you
definitely should display them here the
reason why by the way they don't really
need to appear here because this is
actually a list of files that are
included in the project so if the files
are not included here they're not sent
to the compiler header files do are not
really compiled header files are
included into CPP files so we have like
this vector2.hp file for example it
contains all of this code beautiful but
it only gets compiled when it gets
included into well this is actually
manifold.hp so I guess that gets
included into manifold.cpp this is the
file that is sent to the compiler same
reason why if you go to a header file
you hit Ctrl F7 which is the shortcut to
compile a single file or if you're cool
you could actually go to add remove
buttons customize this is a bit of a
tangent and you could add command to
build compile right so I think it's also
built like build compile or something
this is actually a nice button I like to
have here here it is this little compile
button you can see it's grayed out and
control F7 won't do anything if I switch
to a CPP file though it's not grayed out
anymore and I can click it and it will
just compile a single file so that's why
we we don't actually even need the
header files included in the project
because as far as like the C plus
compiler is concerned all it does is it
simply goes to this file path assuming
that that is relative to a compiler
include directory or relative to this
file itself and it just copies and
pastes the contents of that file and it
does so recursively going through all of
these just became a c plus header files
tutorial you're welcome although I do
have one of those that I filmed outside
in some Park so check that out for more
details it's becoming less of a code
review and more just a channel talks
about programming oh well so how do I
approach going through this project and
I guess learning how it works well the
number one thing I can recommend is to
just use the actual debugging tools that
are inside your IDE so I could just read
this text right I could just read the
fact that the main function calls demo
balls and cube right which is a class
and it calls the Run function I can use
the tools inside my IDE to just jump to
that function and then just learn about
the structure and how it kind of stems
down into all of these functions just by
visually reading and navigating using
the IDE kind of navigation tools that's
cool what's cooler is just running the
program and then using like break points
and various other I guess code like
execution flow commands like step into
step over that kind of stuff to actually
see what happens so here's an example I
could put a breakpoint in here just
setting that using F9 then I'm going to
hit F5 to run actually before I do that
let me just switch to debug mode because
if we're not in debug mode the compiler
will optimize an inline and do a whole
bunch of stuff with our functions and we
just won't be able to see like half of
what's going on so let's go ahead and
hit F5 inside debug mode and you can see
we have a breakpoint here let me just
permanently display this here we know
that we're running this but what does
this call oh I'll just hit f11 or go up
here into the step into button now if
you're not using visual studio the kind
of terminology is virtually identical in
any debugging environment so you'll have
an equivalent for sure unless you're
using thing like a pile of garbage all
right so step into if I click that
button here
you can see we're now in the Constructor
and now if I'm here what I can do is I
can continue kind of stepping into which
will probably take me into like some of
these things like let's just try that
yeah it'll jump up here and that's all
cool and then maybe it will take me into
like Yeah The Constructor of context
settings whatever if I don't really want
to keep going kind of depth first
everywhere and I just want to go almost
breath first and even explaining this
I'm acting like a programmer but
whatever let's just say you want to step
onto the next line without actually
going into the function or the
Constructor or whatever there is a step
over button or F10 right so usually I
use like my keyboard shortcuts for this
so F10 a step over f11 a step into shift
f11 and step out which is a good example
of what we'll use here you can see
because I already stepped into contact
settings if I just hit step over now
it's going to keep going through all
these members that it's initializing but
if I hit step out which is shift f11
then it will take me out so it's going
to run the entirety of whatever scope or
function I'm in and then it's going to
step me out into what called that
function in the first place and that's
what I've done here and then I can just
hit F10 and you can see I'm going
through all this line by line now one
other cool thing you can do that some
people might not be aware of is you can
actually take this this is our kind of
instruction pointer and we can actually
just drag it back
and what it will do is it will run that
code again now it does display a little
warning saying that to change which
statement is executed next track the
arrow this may have unintended
consequences the reason why is because
it's not like it's going to roll back
the program and undo any changes that
have been made as a result of running
those CPU instructions they obviously
have already run yeah if I just hit F10
a couple times I've physically run the
code on my CPU that is inside like
whatever functions or code I've written
that's already been called that's run
that's executed if I drag this back I'm
now executing it again so if I had a
function that added stuff to a list and
it's added five elements to a list I
drag this back and I run it again I'm
going to have 10 elements in the list
right it's going to run that code again
it's not going to undo anything that's
happened that's why sometimes it can
have unintended consequences however in
a lot of cases for example here I'm just
obviously making a unique impulse solve
I'm making a new object and I'm
overwriting the previous instance
assuming that a Constructor of this
doesn't do anything I mean this doesn't
even have a Constructor unless it calls
yet it doesn't do anything right all
it's doing is allocating memory if I
drag this back here it's just
reallocating that memory and like
freeing the last result because I'm like
replacing the unique pointer essentially
so I can run this like as many times as
I want and I'm not going to get any
consequences like happening from that
really same with this smooth position
solver that doesn't really do anything
so this is personally something I use a
lot so for example like why would this
be useful let's just say I'm just going
through this step 10 to 10 of 10 and
let's just say this doesn't work load
from file doesn't work I end up like in
here I might want to step into that
function but I've already like passed
over it no I can drag that back and now
it's actually going to try and load it
again and this time I can hit f11 and
I'm going to end up inside this load
from file function eventually now here's
another little trick that might be
useful sometimes you just can't find the
entry point now in a program this small
and like with this layout it's pretty
easy I mean the file is literally called
main.cvp and it's got this and even if
it didn't have this you could probably
just hit Ctrl shift F and just search
for like main or int main or whatever
and find it or win main if it's like a
Windows application with that entry
point specifically there's ways to find
the entry point is generally pretty easy
but what you could also do right let me
just close like everything let's pretend
I don't know where the main function is
at all nothing exists here blank Visual
Studio solution instead of hitting F5 to
run I can hit F10 or f11 so step over or
step into so let me just hit F10 right
now you can see it started to build and
look at this it's opened up main.cpp at
the very kind of entry point of our
application now this might not be the
entry point of the application because
for example how did this person written
some kind of static initializer like
this right if I hit F10 you can see it's
still taken me to this section of my
code but that's actually not the very
first code inside our application that
was called because if I go into demo
balls and Cube and I put a breakpoint
like I don't know here sure or whatever
and then I hit F10
oh what a surprise I ended up on my
break point here and not over here and
if we look at the call stack we can see
that there's actually some Dynamic
initializer for game two that's been
called over here right and that's
actually coming from this kind of common
main function and we have actually
haven't even called this yet right we're
still here and if I hit F5 from here we
end up on this line of code right so
there's sometimes this code that runs
before the main function this whole main
is the entry point is potentially a lie
depending on how you look at it so my
point being that this kind of like F10
to run might not necessarily be the
first code that you run inside your
entire application it's more so a way
for us to actually kind of find our
entry point and start executing from
there now if I hit f11 it's going to do
the exact same thing and if I put this
back and hit f11 same thing again right
so it's not going to go like into this
and start executing that it's going to
just show me my entry point so that's a
really easy way to just find out where
your entry point is like if I just open
up the Unreal Engine Solution and I have
no idea where on Earth main is and in
fact they might be like several Mains
depending on the current configuration
and all that I can just hit F10 it will
take me there done and from here on out
you can just go through and just see how
the program works cool it's adding all
of these things so this is physically
like what is happening with my program I
can see now just by going through it
using the debugging tools here I can see
exactly what the program's doing without
having to like look at all of these
files and be like oh well you know
trying to piece it together manually is
my point I can just go through this and
it's all easy next up game.ron f11 to
step into that okay it's making a ground
it's setting up a few things we are
clearly adding this ground into this
entities list here starting the main
Loop and then here's the main Loop while
window is open so what what's that doing
if I zoom out a little bit we've got all
of our time and event stuff we've got is
mouse button press otherwise look at
this step into the physics and world dot
steps so that's a good kind of indicator
I guess of where like the physics is
actually taking place and if I just hit
F5 to run to to my next break point like
that because F5 resumes execution and
obviously if it hits a breakpoint it's
going to stop f11 to get into that don't
really care about time as seconds by the
way here's a little quick thing if we
just go back here for a moment sometimes
there's a lot of different functions
that are called on a single line of code
right so Delta time as seconds as an
example of that if I just hit f11 I
accidentally made some changes rip when
that happens sometimes it gets a bit
annoying I could have hit ignore that
but let's not get into it so if I hit
f11 you can see it goes into as seconds
and not world.step now I could obviously
if I go back to where I was hit shift
f11 to go back and then f11 again and in
this case that wasn't too bad it takes
me into this however what can be
annoying is if you have like I don't
know 10 of these or like a few of them
right sometimes you just want to step
into this directly without going
anywhere else how can you do that well
there's two ways you can basically go
into world.step manually and just set a
breakpoint here or even here if you want
hit F5 and you can see it will run to
this right so it's going to skip any
other functions obviously because I've
just told it to run up until it hits
this next breakpoint the other thing you
could do though is just right click and
there's a step into specific
menu option over here and you can just
choose here from any of the functions we
can step into so there's that time as
seconds and there's that Dynamics World
step so if we wanted to go there we
could just right click step into
specific and Dynamics World step the
other really good benefit I guess of
using this kind of stepping through the
debugger thing is if you have a lot of
like inheritance going on and like
derived classes so a lot of these are
like that you can see smooth position
solver is a solver it can be an absolute
nightmare when you have like you know
some kind of Base Class like let's just
say world was a base class but really
that could be one of like three
different implementations you wouldn't
just be able to look at world.step and
immediately see which one was being
called if that makes sense because world
is a base class and it could be one of
three classes and they might all have
different step functions but of course
if you use the debugger clearly your
code execution knows which one is being
used here and so when you step into that
it will step into the correct kind of
derived class so that can be really
helpful as well all right so from there
we can see what happens every single
frame when our kind of physics world is
stepped so apply gravity will apply some
sort of gravity force here which of
course you guys would know all about
because you would have looked at
brilliant and seen all of their kind of
math and physics classes oh what's this
you you haven't heard of brilliant the
sponsor of this video brilliant is an
amazing website filled with many many
courses on various stem topics such as
math and physics and science and
computer science seriously there's so
much on there now if I need to brush up
on my math which sounds like maybe I
don't need that but believe me I do my
favorite place to do that is brilliant
the reason being that all of their
courses are presented in such a great
engaging and visual way that it makes
the learning really fun and effective
it's presented with these widgets that
you can like interact with to see how
the math works and to make sure that
you're actually learning and retaining
the information they will quiz you and
get you to engage with the content to
make sure that you are learning their
library of math courses is huge and goes
all the way down to this everyday math
course which is a fantastic introduction
for those of you who are just getting
into math and wanted to be gentle but
don't take my word for it check it out
yourself the best thing about brilliant
is that you can get started absolutely
for free just go to brilliant.orgno and
take a look at their wide range of high
quality courses brilliant have also been
nice enough to offer the first 200 of my
subscribers 20 off an annual membership
so definitely hurry and sign up it's
such a fantastic way to learn huge thank
you to brilliant for sponsoring this
video so our force is being applied
that's pretty cool I mean again this is
a bit of a code review even though you
know we've talked about this before I
just use the idea of a code review to
try and teach programming I think it's a
good practical way to do that but if we
go a little bit back to the code review
portion of this this code if you just
think about it minus this stupid C plus
plus 20 like whatever on Earth is going
on here I honestly hate this but that's
like let's just kind of move it like
that this code is just so easy to read
like you know we have a rigid body we
have a force we get the gravity force of
the rigid body we multiply it with the
mass of the rigid body and then we call
a function called apply force with the
force right like this code is so
self-documenting it doesn't need stupid
comments being like apply the force to
the rigid body right that does not need
to be here and that's what's so
beautiful about this code should be
self-documenting as much as possible we
write code in English even if it's c
plus blast and that seems like a
low-level language to some people there
are lower level languages out there and
obviously by the time our CPU actually
gets these instructions they're just
machine code and they're completely not
readable we choose to write code in a
language that is readable why so that we
can read it as humans and so that's why
if you're being all cool like with your
little function like stupid names like f
instead of force like it just don't do
that get into the habit of making your
code AS readable as possible it's going
to help you it's going to help your
career if you you plan to work with
other people but again even if you don't
it's going to help you because believe
you me months will pass and you will
forget everything you ever knew and so
coming back to that and and being able
to read your code and make sense of it
is just so beautiful so I really like
the fact that this person has written
their code like this now a little side
note here so I can see there's a
resharper table one CPP style cast which
I'm assuming I don't usually sharper but
I'm assuming this is just a way for for
us to disable like a warning this is
super annoying first of all I hate I
just think that that's absolutely
ridiculous the fact that we have to
letter our code with this garbage to
make that happen now again I don't use
resharper and I'm sure there's probably
a way to globally disable that in the
settings but in general what this is
referring to is the fact that it's
saying that I'm assuming we probably
should have used like a C plus plus
style cast which would look like this if
we wanted to use a static cast so this
I'm assuming is what you would use
personally I'm not a huge fan of CPP
costs and I know that a lot of people
are going to disagree with this that's
totally fine you do you like maybe
sometimes I I would use a dynamic cast
because of like the other properties
that it might have but in general I like
to just use this kind of cast and it's
obviously not an actual compiler warning
it's more of a resharper thing so
honestly like potentially what I would
do is disable it like project wide or
maybe there's a way to do it but like
you know what I mean like it's just
annoying to have this comment seemingly
every time I guess like how many times
do you how many times does this appear
okay only twice in your entire project
for some reason what do you not do costs
anywhere else were you specifically
trying to just do a
say style cost here but you've used like
C plus plus costs everywhere else yeah I
mean that's interesting if I do a little
search it looks like you do use static
casts in other places so I'm not sure
why you didn't use a static cast here
because obviously that would have worked
it's I guess maybe because this is a
polymorphic type you try to do a dynamic
cast which it's not accepting
probably because the Base Class
Collision body
yeah it doesn't have any virtual
functions so the thing is when you have
something like this
you can see that now this works so I
what I've done is body is a collision
body it's a pointer to this class type
but if I don't have any virtual
functions there it gives me an error and
the reason for that is because it's not
considered a polymorphic class type
right that's the error here unless you
actually have like a V table there which
happens when you have virtual functions
which could map to other functions in
the derived class because otherwise if
we just look at this class like there's
nothing here obviously that suggests
it's a base class because all the
functions are here and they're all
implemented that maybe is what happened
just the fact that Dynamic cast didn't
work so you were like I guess I'll use
just a normal C style cast but remember
that anything a dynamic house can do a
static cast can also do static cast can
kind of do anything you want it to
really it's just the differences Dynamic
costs would have verified that it
actually was of that instance
potentially and returned null if it
wasn't instead of just doing the cost
and then the you crash later because May
maybe the memory layout isn't correct or
whatever so yeah I would probably I mean
seeing that you use static cast
everywhere else which is fine totally
acceptable I would just change the code
to that and then get rid of these stupid
comments because I hate them one more
thing that I'm going to nitpick at is
this I personally
do not like
structs to be used as polymorphic types
so this should in my eyes be a class now
why there is literally no real reason
for this there's probably no real reason
for most of what I say however the
reason why is because first of all I
mean you know you you have a public and
protected section anyway with a
structure you actually don't need this
because it's public by default
but you do so in other words there's no
benefit I guess to because the only
difference between instructing a class
is the fact that strikes have public
members by default if you don't specify
like a visibility modifier and classes
are private by default right so if this
was a class and I had nothing here all
of this would be private but if this was
a struct and I had nothing here all of
this would be public that's the only
difference but you've got a public thing
here anyway which means that I can kind
of use these interchangeably and they
will work but the reason is like I like
to personally add some semantics to
structure class so for me structs kind
of represent data only objects I guess
kind of like a pod type plain old data
but not like necessarily like you can
still provide functions there maybe it
even has a Constructor so like a good
example of a struct might be like Factor
two because I want to have like let's
just say float X and Y you can see
they're public because I'm trying to
make the data transparent accessible and
I'm not going to have private kind of
areas here where I have like additional
data or anything like that yeah that's
not kind of this is already getting too
complex so I like to keep structs Simple
that's the meaning that I just assigned
to them because in my eyes it kind of
makes sense Strokes are designed to be
public by default so it's just a way for
me to tie variables together into a
structure that's kind of what a struct
is and of course the reason they're like
this is because structs map directly to
C C does not have class as a keyword
it's only got structs and it doesn't
have public private protected there's no
visibility modifiers in C because
there's no objects really or classes so
you just wind up with structs being
public by default because this is
compatible with C but of course in C
plus where we do have classes and we do
have visibility modifiers their use
becomes a little bit well it did not
needed to be completely honest because
you can do the exact same thing with a
class there does not have to be two
keywords struct in class where one of
them is magically public by default and
the other one is private by default but
yet we have this again for that
compatibility with C so that we could
just include like a C file or a dot h
file that is written like in the C
programming language and everything will
compile fine my mostly because we have
that compatibility in the safe plus
compiler so yeah this is one of those
things where I like to assign my own
meaning to it because it's kind of you
don't really need it so we might as well
take advantage of it and that's kind of
the meaning I signed to it and one of my
rules is that I don't have any kind of
inheritance going on with structs right
so in other words I wouldn't have that
rigid body
see again really annoying I wanted to
open up the razor body header file of
course I did but there is no I had a
file because you haven't included in the
project so it's just rigidbody.cvp and
then I have to switch on over into this
and then here obviously you it is a
subclass of this and you have public
here and private and like again it would
function if I just change this to class
right now the only thing I'm actually
going to have to change as well is that
if I go back here I'll have to make sure
this is public because otherwise it
won't quite work that way with classes
but anyway if these are the only two
changes I make and I just compile your
entire project you can see that's done
right I mean I've only compiled this
static Library
but if we build demo as well yeah there
we go no problems no warnings nothing
like that everything's beautiful because
it's such a minor change however to me
when I look at it and I see that it's a
class okay it's more of a complex type
it's not just like a struct of data so
that's just again very subjective just
my opinion but that's kind of how I like
to deal with like structs versus classes
and trying to decide which like should
this be a structure this be a class okay
and then if we quickly look at the apply
Force function okay pretty basic this
just does this for some reason you've
got this here but Force plus equals
added Force I don't know why you've done
this because you haven't done it
anywhere else I'm sure it's just like a
typo or something
um but you can obviously just do this uh
same as you've done over here this is
another good example of why it's nice to
have these you know be called not just
that because it means that if you do
have some kind of convention where you
add something special at the front for
members it means that if you have a
parameter of the same name you can do
this without having to use this I don't
know why I'm getting all these errors
Suddenly It's probably just just visual
studio just Visual Studio being Visual
Studio yep just gonna display these
errors here until the end of time okay
whatever you do you but yeah if these
were called the same thing like if I had
Force like that and then this is also
called Force then I would have to write
you know this Arrow Force equals force
so that I can tell it that I'm referring
to the member rather than the uh
parameter name because they have the
same name which we should ultimately
avoid and we can do that by having this
little
thing um I saw someone in the comments
of the previous video was saying that uh
they wouldn't do underscore like they
wouldn't have like a leading underscore
because that's kind of reserved for
compiler internal things
this is kind of true although my
suspicion is it kind of differs per
compiler like for example everything
inside Visual Studio always has a double
underscore right so whether that be like
uh Visual Studio only or mspc only
function like debug break or even like
some kind of
um you know like here we have like a
variable type which is just a like
128-bit SSE register here like that all
uses double underscores so for me that's
not that big of a deal I suspect that
maybe like can GCC a clang maybe they
have single underscores but me
personally in my code I always as I
mentioned I use like M underscore I
don't just do underscore only but yeah I
mean I think that you know if especially
if you're using visual studio and you're
compiling with msvc I don't think you'll
get any problems with single underscores
like this
all right well I've just spent most of
the day talking about like debugging and
stuff so I guess take three next time
we'll talk about the physics I don't
know you guys enjoying these code
reviews where I just talk about code I
mean I guess code programming that's
kind of the subject of these videos let
me know what your thoughts are in the
comment section below but I hope you
guys enjoyed this code review if you did
please don't forget to hit the like
button remember you can send in your
code to channelreview gmail.com there
are some instructions on how to do that
and what like information to include in
the description you could be next once
we actually get to the physics engine
don't forget to check out brilliant and
learn something and I will see you guys
next time goodbye
foreign
[Music]